affirmative action fits right within
this if you say well okay we'd like to
help a certain set of people
what you are going to have to do is
discriminate against another set of
people and then you say okay well these
people can get into a school in an
easier way and in grad school in an
easier way and a job in an easier way at
some point whatever job you're trying to
put them into whatever it is that you're
whatever you're trying to get them into
be it an airline pilot or a heart
surgeon you're going to have lower
quality people because the top the
number one thing when hiring for an
important job would be the highest
qualification so you wouldn't want to
look at someone's genitals
board anyway this is just incredible
watch this so uh this is North Carolina
Senator Ted Budd and he is asking a uh a
nominee to be FAA administrator his last
name's Washington
um which probably is racist but he's
black so what are you gonna do about FAA
policy now if you wanted to be the FAA
administrator you know I'm not a uh you
know I'm not an expert in avionics or
whatever but if you wanted to be in
charge of the FAA you'd have to know a
lot about flying I would imagine policy
related to flying things of that nature
so they have these hearings because they
want to know that this guy's qualified
for the job this is absolutely
extraordinary the man wants to be the
FAA administrator watch these questions
from Ted bud and you tell me if this guy
should get the job so Mr Washington can
you quickly tell me uh what airspace
requires an adsb transponder not sure I
can answer that question right now
that's okay we'll just keep going so um
that's a that's a pretty and important
part so what are the six types of
special use airspace that protect this
National Security that appear on FAA
charts uh sorry Senator I cannot answer
that question okay so what are the
operational limitations of a pilot
flying under basic Med Senator I'm not a
pilot so obviously you'd ever see the
Federal Aviation Administration so
um any idea what those restrictions are
under basic Med quickly
well some of the restrictions I think
would be high blood pressure some of
them would be it's more like how many
passengers per airplane how many pounds
in different categories and uh what what
altitude you can fly under so and uh and
then
uh amount of knots it's under 250 knots
so it's not having anything to do with
blood pressure so can you tell me what
causes an aircraft to spin or to stall
again Senator I'm not a pilot
um okay uh let's keep going what are the
three aircraft certifications FAA
requires as part of the manufacturing
process quickly please
three aircraft certifications
again what I would say to that is that
one of my first priorities would be to
fully Implement that certification act
uh and Report you know the three types
Mr Washington that the three types okay
he's gonna get the job like he's gonna
get the job I'm telling you I'm going to
learn how to fly a plane that's it I'm
getting my pilot's license I'm not
kidding
thank you
[Music]